[Musique]
ça les enfants et bonsoir les jolies
petites araignées qui se promène dans
l'effort de sapins sapins et de branche
en branche
alors nounours tu descends oui patron
mais prudemment je descend très
prudemment
et hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
hop est entré
il n'y a plus de toile d'araignée
il ya quelqu'un là tant
boussouar juliette pas ma belle tu es
salle
il n'ya plus d'araignée mais c'est
extraordinaire
un ballet vite un ballet là il vaut
mieux faire le ménage après le passage
de pareilles bestioles
[Musique]
lui de toiles d'araignées
les deux nuits à poster
et voilà ce que bon ce ballet au o2
malade à un
dada excusez-moi cherrad le salariat
j'ai la tête solide mais où sont les
enfants ce soir
il arrive à mi il arrive qu'on est en
voilà salut ces araignées elles sont
introuvables elles sont sorties se
promener avec le soleil et elles ont
retrouvé une étable où un grenier à foin
au jeu lui à tort veux tu me laisser des
toyer socoa au long
qu'est ce que ça veut dire et un
japonais l'acca qui
regarde sous chiffon à la cacher quelque
chose et voilà un biscuit aux biscuits
oui elle cache ses petites provisions
elle n'est pas contente quand on fait le
ménage
[Musique]
autre pépite en
eau le volant repartie elle va revenir à
présent allons voir dans la chambre
ne t'énerve pas julietta ça ne sert à
rien
là dedans c'est plein de bonnes choses
n'est ce pas juliette à eau
douce regard au le cocu
morceau de fromage une souris n'est pas
peur elle est un gâteau six ans je mets
préféré une femme
vient pepita ja voir juliette en colère
ou
bien sert faut toucher à ses prévisions
et à ses joueurs il faut les laisser là
où elle le cache est vrai bien regard
giulietta nous mettons tout en place là
où
[Musique]
quoi qu'est ce que seul
venait d'en voir mon ours venait de voir
monde
c'est une araignée
aux pépites à tuer aussi coquine que
juliette a attendez que je vous attrape
toi et ton araignées
et bien mon petit cornichons moi aussi
je me sauve balleux nuit tout le monde
au revoir ferrat mis aux voix le nouveau
[Musique]
ollon nounours en route il est tard je
pars tranquille pas trop tout est en
ordre dans la roulotte quoique avec ces
petites pépites à on ne sait jamais
bonne nuit des enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents n'oubliez pas de faire
votre toilette et de bien vous laver les
dents allez vite vous couchez sagement
et pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]